It’s been almost a year since the world changed
forever, not that anyone still human had really
been counting the days. Almost a year since
the sun forsook its children and changed its
rays from life-giving gifts to flesh-melting
weapons more fitting of Hell than Heaven.
In the first hours of the chaos, billions
were changed irreparably into abominations
of flesh. That day when day broke permanently
altered the course of history. The remaining
personnel at the SCP Foundation classified
it SCP-001, but what good could they do now?
It was, for all intents and purposes,
the end of the world as we knew it.
Would anything ever be as it was before? No,
in all likelihood, the world as we once knew
it is little more than a dying memory in the
minds of those who even bother remembering
the times before. They’ll do little to
help you in this terrible new reality,
where even stepping outside can be a
gateway to a fate so much worse than death.
Huge, fleshy monsters slither
through the streets, day and night,
ceaselessly hunting for more victims to drag
out into the horrors of daylight and join their
ever-growing forms. When it happened, planes
fell out of the sky like deadly hailstones,
devastating the ground underneath in a volley
of explosions that left so much of our world
scarred. Cars and trucks careened off the road
and into buildings and ditches as their drivers,
exposed by the windows around
them, took on a liquid state.
The surviving humans are in hiding - Many,
like you or me, want to survive and be safe
for another day. Others, who lost their minds
during the change or perhaps were always cruel
and monstrous underneath it all, lurked in the
darkness waiting for others they could destroy,
with no law or order to stop them from
indulging in their worst pleasures now.
Anyone who had survived this long was smart,
lucky, or some cursed combination of the two.
One Wanderer, named David, didn’t quite
know which group he’d classify himself
as. He wandered through what had once been
the streets of New York City, every inch of
his body covered up with a special anti-sun
suit of his own making. In the early days,
the SCP Foundation had mass-released tutorials
on how to build full-body coverage suits out
of clothes and everyday household objects. This
had likely saved many lives - Or at least served
to extend them for a while. Sometimes,
that was the best you could hope for.
David knew where he was going: A
nearby underground parking complex,
completely covered up beneath the earth,
where no natural light would reach. The
people down there had constructed their own
generators to have working electricity for
emergencies and blocked off any stairs or
roadways to another level. The only way up
or down was a single elevator shaft that they
owned and operated. It was the best way to keep
one of those blobby monsters from descending and
dragging them all up to the horrors of daylight.
David found the place, deftly avoiding any of
the monsters still roaming the streets. He’d been
out on a food run, collecting canned goods from
distant bodegas: Tuna, spam, hotdogs, soups. They
sent out four scavengers a day in hopes of keeping
their food supplies well-stocked, drawing straws
each day to decide fairly. Today, David had been
one of them, and it had been a good day - in so
far as any day can be good in this world. On some
days, when they’d sent out four scavengers, only
one, two, or none at all had returned. Such is the
way with the world of the broken sun. You quickly
lost your sense of what’s “fair” if you wanted to
survive here. David had learned that the hard way.
He reached the elevator, powered by the generators
below, and knocked the secret code onto the metal
to get the doors to open. He slipped inside, and
once the security camera above saw it was him,
it descended. Soon enough, he was with the
others, handing in that night’s takings so
they could pool their resources and
the most experienced cooks among them
could prepare tonight’s dinner. They took small
pleasures in life whenever they could be found.
Later that same evening, David, and four
others - Gus, Addison, Charlie, and Mike - sat
around a campfire, eating cooked spam out of
their respective cans with scavenged forks.
They did all they could to contact the
world outside: Posting messages online,
coded audio over any working radio and HAM
frequencies, even leaving notes out in the
open with clues to their location, where
the blobs - whose minds were as melted
and warped as their bodies - could never
find them. They received correspondences
from all over the new world, and with them
came plenty of interesting new stories to
share. So that was precisely what they did
around the underground campfire every night,
using filters they’d stolen from above to keep
the air pure. They told each other stories.
Gus had heard an interesting one. Apparently,
out West, there was some kind of monster - a
Sculpture, made out of concrete and rebar, that
only moved when you weren’t looking at it. This
beast stalked through the dark, seemingly
indestructible, and would snap the necks of
anyone and everyone it managed to get its rusty
stretches of rebar on. In the world before,
this would have seemed impossible. But here
and now, they were willing to believe it.
Charlie told the story of a different beast.
They’d heard tales of a group of people who
were holed up inside a mall in Pittsburgh,
trying to wait out the horrors. Nobody brought
up the Dawn of the Dead reference lurking
in there. But apparently, something else
was lurking in there too. One day, everyone
who’d been hiding in the mall was attacked
and slaughtered by some horrifying reptile that
tunneled out of the ground with giant claws,
and murdered almost all of them in cold
blood. The one that escaped had been telling
his story to anyone who listened. Nobody knew
where the giant reptile would turn up next.
Addison tried to introduce a note of hope
with her story. She’d heard that out there,
there was some mad genius working on a cure. A man
who always wore a black cloak and a white mask,
like one of those old-fashioned Plague Doctors.
He’d come closer than anybody else to synthesizing
a cure, and he and all the others with him
were holed up in an SCP Foundation site,
accepting help from anyone who happened
to wander by. It would certainly be a
nice story if it were true. But nobody
could really know for sure, could they?
Mike added a note of caution with his
story. He’d heard of another group of
survivors who made their way to one of those
so-called SCP Foundation containment sites,
but they’d found it abandoned, devoid of
the many experts and saviors that the SCP
Foundation had promised in all of those old
broadcasts. Instead, they were greeted by a
nightmare. A ghoulish old man covered in black
slime, with a permanent sadistic grin on his
face. He could walk through walls and melt
off skin with his burning touch. He’s always
out there, just waiting for more unfortunate,
hope-filled victims to fall into his clutches.
That sent a shudder through them all. What
had happened? Of course, there was the obvious
problem of the treacherous burning sun up
above, and its melted minions down below,
but how had the world suddenly become so beset
with these terrible monsters? It was like the
gates of hell had opened, and all manner
of beasts had come spilling out. All that
the human race could do now was survive,
but every day, the world seemed a little
less worth surviving for. Why were they here?
Just to be prey for these nightmare creatures?
David, who had been silent up to this point,
finally spoke up, asking, “Have any
of you heard of the Black Warrior?”
There was silence. None had heard of this
one before. They waited and listened.
“He saved my life,” David went on.
“And I’d guess I’m not the only one.”
The incident, as David told it, had happened weeks
ago, before he’d even joined up with this current
group. He’d lost everything and everyone, and was
left wandering the wastes of New York City alone.
He’d been hiding in the dark of an old financial
building for so long, but his food supply had
run completely dry. He would simply need to
leave - He knew that if he waited any longer,
even a few more hours without food, he’d
pass out and die of starvation in his sleep,
or be killed by one of those things. He’d
need to go out in daylight and forage. It
was the only way. He’d already built a total
coverage suit. What did he have to lose?
That very thought would bring him closer
to death than he’d ever been before.
David wandered out, half delirious with
hunger, trying to find a store that hadn’t
been looted or burned down to nothingness.
His vision was hazy. He needed something
to eat and, ideally, something to drink, too.
He felt happier than he’d ever remembered
being when he came across an abandoned
Japanese grocery store and filled up on
stale rice and several bottles of Ramune
like some con-going teenager. However,
while he may have just saved his life in one
way, he’d put it in grave danger in another.
The second he stepped out of the store, one
of those giant, terrible flesh monsters saw
him. His heart almost stopped as this mountain
of rancid, liquefied meat slithered towards him
at shocking speed, sprouting a series of long
tentacles, ready to grab him, tear off his suit,
and add him to its terrible collective. Trying
to save his own life had seemingly killed him.
Of course, David tried to run, but it was
already too late. He felt the tendrils grab
him and lift him off the air, pulling him
towards the immense and terrible flesh of
this rampaging superorganism. It called out
in so many warped voices at once, crying for
terrible unity. David knew that in mere moments,
it’d tear off his suit, and suddenly, he’d be
worse than dead. But it seemed that luck was
about to shine on him in the strangest of ways.
Every single one of the flesh monster’s gibbering
voices became unified in a blood-curdling scream.
Something swung down and cleaved the mountain
in half, splitting it cleanly into two smaller
blobs. The tendrils immediately retracted,
and David was dropped to the ground as the
two smaller, shrieking blobs slithered
off, terrified, in different directions.
At first, David had no idea what had just
happened as he began picking himself up
from the ground. Then, he saw the silhouette
of a mighty figure standing a few feet away,
holding a bigger sword than he’d thought
would be possible for a normal human to carry.
But this was no normal human
if it was even human at all.
He stood seven feet tall, built like an
old marble statue. Every single inch of
his body was covered in obsidian
armor, completely protecting the
warrior underneath from the oppressive rays
of the sun. This was the figure that David,
and all the others who’d encountered him, had
taken to calling the Black Warrior. Nobody
knew who he was underneath. All they knew was
that he wandered the new world, day and night,
slaughtering the beasts of the sun. He feared
nothing, and everyone else knew to fear him.
David was on his back, staring with
disbelief at the Black Warrior. The
Warrior exhaled and began to walk towards
him. David cowered as he approached,
but the Warrior simply kept walking past him.
Confused and delirious with a mix of
fear and relief, David called out,
“Wait, aren’t you going to kill me?”
Without breaking stride, the Black Warrior
replied, “Where’s the honor in stomping on ants?”
And with that, he was gone. He’d saved
David’s life and then compared its value
to that of an ant. That was the Black
Warrior, it seemed. He was neither
a hero nor a villain in the new world,
just a man looking to pick a good fight.
And from the casualness with which he performed
every action, even cleaving the abominable
flesh monsters, it was likely he hadn’t
faced an opponent he considered worthy… Yet.
Once David had told his story, there
was silence around the campfire. David
would never know if the others believed his
story or whether they thought it was just
the ramblings of a terrified man who’d just
gotten lucky. But we know that David wasn’t
lying about the Black Warrior. Of course,
that was a relatively recent name for him.
The SCP Foundation had known him mainly as
SCP-076-2, but to himself, he was always Able.
It had been Able’s second resurrection into
the world of When Day Breaks. In his first,
he’d decided to do something bold and daring.
He’d stormed Site-19 at its weakest moment,
forcing several other anomalies
to assist him in his bloody quest
to strike back against the SCP Foundation.
He’d followed and taunted Dr. Jack Bright,
then beaten this immortal of his own creation
within an inch of his latest life. Bright,
however, had managed to get the jump on Able
by transferring his soul into the body of one
of those fleshy abominations, then using his
collective strength to crush Able to death.
Of course, for Able, just like Dr. Bright, death
had only ever been a temporary inconvenience.
Several months later, he’d once again
resurrected from his black sarcophagus,
his mind still swimming with the memories of
his last life. He wandered out into the now
empty Containment Area 25b, littered with
the bodies of the guards and researcher
he’d killed during his last escape.
Pathetic. They’d posed no challenge.
What would, however, pose a challenge
to him would be the sun outside. He
remembered last time that the
sun had somehow changed. Now,
anyone exposed to its rays would be melted
into one of those… things. Able was intelligent
enough to realize that this was something
he might not be able to regenerate from.
He needed a more permanent solution.
But Able had spent his last several
thousand years walking this earth,
coming up with extremely permanent
solutions to all of his problems,
and this would be no exception. He would
need to wear armor, armor that covered
every inch of his skin. It would be the
only way he could move safely out there.
Of course, he wouldn’t be caught dead
in the garb of the SCP Foundation - his
pathetic would-be jailers, who had
fallen in droves in the face of this
new threat. He would make his own
armor, the way that only he could.
In case anyone needs a refresher, one of
Able’s primary anomalous abilities - In
addition to his ability to resurrect himself
and his superhuman strength, speed, durability,
and combat prowess - is his innate ability to
pull a limitless number of obsidian weapons out
of miniature localized pocket dimensions.
Swords, axes, clubs, chainsaws, scythes,
spears, hooks, maces, flails, tridents, knives,
cleavers… Almost anything you can imagine. But
Able’s deadliest weapon of all was his brain.
And it was with that, and a combination of all
his other weapons, that Able would figure
the perfect way out of this situation.
First of all, he produced a mountain of weapons
within the site, a huge pile that would make
an army of medieval knights go weak at the
knees. But he would not use these weapons
for their intended purpose. Instead, he went
about searching the building for materials he
could use in his brand-new project. All he needed
was sufficient metal he could bend into place,
and a blast furnace - One that he would eagerly
use the site’s in-built nuclear warhead,
designed for the explicit purpose of killing
him during an escape, to instead facilitate
his new life in this new world. What a
wonderful plan it was shaping up to be.
It took him several days to achieve his goal
and a few humiliating failures along the way,
but Able was eventually able to create
a sufficiently robust furnace to melt
down the many weapons he’d pulled from
the ether, and begin to make something
new out of their molten extracts. Able
was a holistically brilliant warrior,
and to achieve that title, one can not only
learn how to fight but how to maintain one’s
arsenal and how to be an adept smithy. The
latter skill would serve able well here.
He used his own molten weapons to construct
the perfect battle armor, armor that would
cover his body entirely and protect him from the
deadly sun above. He made several prototypes,
testing each one by dressing up one
of the many Foundation corpses in it,
and pushing it out into the sun.
The first few soon had liquefied
human leaking out of its seams, so Able
knew he needed to iterate and improve.
Thankfully, despite what his bloodthirsty demeanor
might tell you, Able could be very patient when
he needed to be - especially when that patience
could lead to greater bloodshed down the line.
More weapons, more melting, more forging,
more improving. Little by little,
Able was building himself the perfect suit
to venture out into the sunlight and find
new prey. New battles. New violence. He
couldn’t be happier with the results.
Soon enough, Able found a variation
that prevented even his dead test
subjects from melting. It was perfect. He
even melted down the tinted glass of some
Foundation tactical riot helmets to give
his own helm a black visor, just in case.
He had done it, and now, with his new armor
assembled and worn on his huge, muscular body,
he was ready to go out there and make a new name
for himself. Even if all those who remembered
Able were gone, the others would remember the
Black Warrior forever, in reverence and fear.
Able produced a new sword to go with
his new look - A massive, weighted,
double-sided beast of a blade, one that
almost nobody but Able would be able to
carry. A sword that would be part of his legend
forevermore. Oh, this would be so much fun.
For the first time since day had
broken that anybody had done so,
Able stepped out into the sunlight and smiled.
Now go check out SCP-001 When Day
Breaks Dr Bright and SCP-001 When
Day Breaks SCP-682 for more terrifying
tales from the world of When Day Breaks!